hello guys I'm righteous the Ryan Wright
and I'm radical Ryan [ __ ]
we did a Broadway - in bro on the cuff
people that's what this channel is all
about today we're gonna check out the
trailer for American Hero starring the
iconic actor Stephen Dorff you might
know from blade he's done a few other
things yes anyway Melbourne is not like
other people we came to discover he had
abilities to move objects using only the
power is mom cool yes almost all for the
world so attentively
never better
your heart stopped beating for several
minutes if you're certified dead I'm
gonna change I'm even thinking about
stopping jerking off
yeah I wouldn't go reco
you started a war we can't fight
do they look
hey bite down we're trying to know their
mother that looks fantastic yeah that's
cool that's more long that seems more
along the lines of what I wanted Hancock
to be that I was just gonna say well
it's a more badass version of Hancock
like the less pg-rated yeah cuz this
guy's like a druggie he's he's kind of a
criminal I like the idea of how he has
like he almost dies so it's like a human
we can relate to that like having a wake
up call Hancock was like other planets
and stuff right yeah Hancock went a
little bit out there and it didn't
really have a consistent tone I feel
like the visual style of this is cool
was it found footage or not the
beginning shot was definitely a handheld
camera and that second to last shot was
also found and they talk to the camera a
lot I'm pretty sure it's mockumentary
style almost like the effects were
really cool too I like an independent
feature film that knows like its limits
but takes advantage of its limits at the
same time yeah because they can't go as
big Hollywood sci-fi as as like
something like Hancock would be able to
do but they're actually using it to
their advantage it looks cooler and more
gritty and realistic catching both the
what did he grab the beer bottles you
got beer in a bottle of vodka yeah
that's that's awesome because that's
what appealed to me about Hancock I not
to keep comparing it but like watching
trap for this I'm like I would totally
if I had powers that would be me well
the thing is okay so you always look at
these superheroes and stuff right and
one of them smoke weed yeah you know
none of them have sex this guy you know
this would be us he just seems like a
real dude yeah like oh yeah his friend
is dying from drug overdoses yeah
exactly that's awesome sleeping in
gutters that's us for a lot some
plaining not jerking off because you
think it does something to you I haven't
washed this sweater in two weeks I
haven't jerked off in two hours
this life is [ __ ] hard hard yeah I
understand what he's going is an
American Hero this guy yeah and Stephen
Dorff looks like he's doing a fantastic
you know Wesley Snipes immediately I was
Eddie Griffin damn it it was like I
like one shot and you said the thing
with am I gonna get this wrong - you
said blade before yeah yeah and I guess
maybe thought Wesley Snipes was like I
thought I was like them collaborate
that's why it was like in my mind so I
got man it's the second like faux pas
yeah you come across so why when you did
that you gotta be careful
oh saying faux pas people know I'm happy
no no no the whole Wesley Snipes thing I
was just gonna give the definition of a
faux pas what's a faux pas a football is
a social misstep so you say something
that you did yeah that's exactly what
I'm talking about so a faux pas can also
be being racist which you're calling me
I'm a walking faux pas so you come
across racist but you're not racist
exactly right just be you know what all
my white friends say I'm not racist I
feel like I can get away with more if
they don't know I'm half way part of the
great for you to move this country
seeing Eddie Griffin back he's been out
of the spotlight for a long time where
was he been um
chilled with Wesley hey Griffin was
funny man undercover brother
yeah it has been a while since a long
time it's like this dude - Stephen Dorff
yeah yeah I'm honestly loving the way
these action sequences look yeah like
really loving the way they look the way
they're capturing every mic when he's
sticking his head out the top of the car
and then he flips the one truck over
that was gracious my favorite part of
these movies though and I think this is
true with a lot of movies is like the
first 30 minutes though when you really
get to see him spiral downwards and use
his powers in the most dramatic
self-destructive ways I love that [ __ ]
yeah lasts long enough though yeah it
doesn't I'm hoping that when he like has
the has to go to the hospital that's
actually like halfway through the movie
the last 15 minutes yeah because I would
I would gladly watch this guy singing in
the church is the last scene yeah yeah
it goes back to it's kind of like the
Good Will Hunting you know this guy has
a lot of potential but he's not
harnessing it on it just like Hancock
it's one of my favorite movies good one
thing oh yeah dude it's a great movie
yeah it's not your fault it's not your
fault stop saying that man it's not your
fault stop saying that man it's not your
fault right right it's not your fault
let's say that right it's not your fault
it's not it's Tamara Tamara
it's not your fault it was my fault I
slept with your girlfriend I'm sorry so
smoke yeah man it's it's a long story
but so you really did go to see better
your ass cheated on you with many people
she's a [ __ ] yeah and she's getting put
on some way to use a fat [ __ ] I guess
we could put her whole put aside this
whole finding myself thing for a while
yeah just blame her for everything it'll
do you really good in life don't ask
yourself why you attracted such a sly
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm turning into Jason
bored that's not Jason boy come on
that's how he developed amnesia so much
you have to block it out of him yeah
well I had nothing to do with the video
you guys are new to the channel so you
can subscribe I ate in this butter to
bug me become a reject Oh bot you know
Autobots I totally get it okay good and
become a rice septagon
with Ryan shoes yeah sometimes I just
think I'm so funny and he's on Facebook
Instagram Twitter starved the movie the
gallows he holds the camera for most of
the film but there are two very three
four or five maybe very good parts where
you get to see my face yeah I don't
eighty minutes you know you watch those
scenes over and over oh yeah I was on a
Ryan shoes interview binge today there's
some good ones out there do a shout-out
thanks man
Scott Patterson hey Ryan I just want to
say watching the rejects brings a smile
to my face
even when the videos can get weird or
creepy you somehow make me laugh I'd
love to get a shout out but even if I
don't I'm not bothered I just want you
and all your fellow reactors to know
you're amazing you know I like the fact
that he was like willing to let go of
the fact that if he didn't get a shout
out like I shout out anyone on this page
but he was like if you want to skit me
totally understand and I love that
sacrifice self-sacrifice humility
you're a real reject Abad you see you
see what we did yeah brought it back
circles continue being a rejected boxer
comes with no [ __ ] no friends and your
family leaves you - I'm not a reject
Avadh I had [ __ ] anti friends you
happier girl man she's really just a lot
more dick than you get [ __ ] let's
probably bet she gets a lot more digging
I don't know about that
I get way more take the natural